[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Roger Bennett founder of
men in Blazers joining us uh now to uh
the celebration here Messi is coming to
the United States you said it would
never happen Roger and it has
Danny pay it was a joy to listen to the
commissioner of the NBA who looks like
my eldest son he is so gorgeous to
follow him is an absolute delight and to
be here with you on the day which is for
all who love the growth of football in
this nation this beautiful Nation it is
incredible Lionel Messi to be like if
LeBron decided so the Lakers I'm gonna
go to China I'm gonna play for the
Shanghai sharks I'm going to do
commercial deals all over that great
nation
um that's what Messi's doing by coming
here conspiracy theories I'm sorry he
doesn't own Apple uh he may play in a
provisor that may be he may play
football still score a couple of hat
tricks but he's coming it's a very
creative deal to make him come
um and I think for Miami it's probably
the greatest day in that City's history
since Don Johnson discovered tail oh
okay I like that
okay how does this affect what is this
effect who's this effect
now while America clearly from your last
caller now has conspiracy theories about
football which is progress right all
right
um I mean it's immense just to be clear
America's had Pele you probably remember
him that um Dan yeah Beckham came here
that is this times a thousand I mean
this is the gentleman
um who yes he's 35 but he's the greatest
player of his Generation
Um he's just come off what was a bit
like in Greek Epic Times there'd be
poems written about him the Argentinian
World Cup win in December he delivered
glory to that Nation I think they've
just finished the Bender uh of
Celebration that started
um in the wake of that and this is
bigger than Pele oh my God yeah I mean
we're living in a different world we're
living in a wired World we're living in
a interconnected world you know little
messy may only be five foot seven but he
is a human billboard that is visible
from space we always say the Great Wall
of China is visible from space it's not
but Atlanta messy what he does how he
plays what where he gets his Kane asada
where he walks his giant dog senior Hulk
all of these make Global News the second
it occurs and it resounds across the
world and for that to happen in MLS you
know a league that to be candid needed
an identity
um yeah the great players were not
coming here they were going to South
Saudi Arabia is offering oil refineries
to any great player who wants to go
there Lionel Messi's wife did not want
did not fancy bringing up the three kids
in an oil refinery yeah go figure
how about Miami we got an apartment
there and credit MLS you know the young
American players they're all leaving
America they want to play in the best
teams in your pulisic cheers your Geo
Rayners your Tyler Adams they want to
play for the best teams they can in
Europe so MLS needed an identity and
credit them they went out and got the
biggest face uh in the global game and
he will be playing ticket sales have
gone up like you you know what you watch
on StubHub how quickly they shot up to
from Face Value x a thousand uh into
Miami's Instagram which was a million
this time yesterday I think it's just
top five million
um stadia will be packed this is going
to be the Beatles reforming playing and
cross our nation and kids in all serious
than kids will be able to pay witness
um to the greatest footballer who have
ever seen I'm not a religious man but
I've watched him play I've watched him
playing Barcelona I've watched him play
in Paris
um and it is spiritual watching this
tiny human being
um who is it's like the Dalai Lama in
cleats
where does he rank greatest players of
all time
Christian pulisic number one and
probably Lionel Messi
a little unless the eclipse second okay
all right I respect that he is I mean
this gentleman is diminutive he looks
like he's just wandered out of your
local Supercuts
um but there's a there's a great poet in
Uruguay Eduardo Galliano uh who sadly
died uh recently but I interviewed him
once
um and he said you know Maradona uh
played as if the ball was stuck to his
shoe to his boot to his cleat he said
Lionel Messi plays as if that ball is
actually inside his sock and it is
incredible
um what he does but it's not just what
he does on the field it's what he does
off it and Lionel Messi uh going
courtside at the heat Lionel Messi you
know going down to high five Patrick the
Holmes before a Chiefs Dolphins game You
Know Jack Harlow jetting in for every
single game that he plays that's the
circus uh times a million that we're
about to see and when you project that
forward commercially with a World Cup
coming here in 2026 Mexico Canada the
United States those two forces together
Dan
um all of your fans who are probably
tweeting and be like no suck it then
what is this remember Jack Kemp didn't
die so that this football could be
considered football
um they're going to be genuinely very
difficult is this a greater moment for
the United States or a dis a bigger
disappointment for Europe or soccer uh
outside the United States that Messi has
come come here
um
well question look the Saudi thing is is
slightly insane the live golf that
you've no doubt talked about at the
Wazee what's their end game in Saudi
Arabia with Gathering all these soccer
players to own The Dan Patrick Show to
be all of our bosses Dan we're all gonna
work why are they doing it
um not to get all geopolitical on your
ass for a second
um but Saudi Arabia
um you know the gulf it's a it we did a
whole podcast series about it with
crooked media called World corrupt why
would Qatar this tiny country won the
World Cup why would FIFA give them the
World Cup those are the two questions we
looked at and the reality is
um geopolitically Saudi Arabia is in a
complex place it has infinite money
um as a Petro state but it also has a
deeply complicated reality deeply
complicated is doing a lot of work there
Dan they murdered khashoggi
um the bombing of Yemen the human rights
record
um that's rationally deeply challenging
to a lot of people however Sports is not
rational Sports is emotional when we
watch sports we've the guitar thing in
the run up to kativ almost like oh my
God we must protest and then Messi run
through five players scored an equipment
like oh my god did you see that guitar's
amazing and so by linking
uh Formula One uh by owning golf uh by
owning football teams you know Saudi
Arabia and Newcastle qatarin Paris
Saint-Germain Manchester City are
playing the Champions League final on
Saturday they're owned
um by Abu Dhabi you can and if you speak
to the Manchester City human beings it's
quite interesting they bought Manchester
City on the same day as they spent like
I can't remember the number something
like a hundred times what they spent on
Manchester City they spent on a um a
tech plant in California is about to
make chips and what they couldn't
believe was the chip plant was a local
news story and a tech story minor Miner
oh this this Tech plant sold the
Manchester City story was heard all
around the world yeah and when you buy
Global football you are buying the
greatest platform to communicate to
Rebrand oh we're not Saudi Arabia of the
khashoggi bone Source we see on
Newcastle did you see we've got Messi
walking here's Saudi Arabia's tourist
Ambassador Ronaldo plays here and that's
ultimately they want the World Cup the
short answer is they want the 2030 World
Cup to be in Saudi Arabia and the way
things are going what does football like
more than anything not rationality not
geopolitics oh money
they probably won't when do we get
Ronaldo
where who's we The Dan Patrick shows
MLS does MLS
have you smelled Ronaldo before
okay great questions in 2012.
um I was in donetsch in Ukraine an
internet the Euros the football
tournament
um and I my hotel room I couldn't you
know what do you hate when you arrive in
a city when you get to the hotel and
they're like sorry your room's not ready
I was like so I did the thing you did
what my room
and they're like sir the check-in is
three o'clock well it's 12 30 and
finally I made dinner for the first that
they put me in a room and it was quite a
nice room
um and um what happened was Portugal
played Spain the night before it
actually been at the game and um they'd
lost and so Portugal flew home and I
walked into that room I opened the door
and my Lord
it smelt of Drac on the wall it took me
months to get rid of the stench of
dracon the war and I said to the hotel
manager who showed me in with the key I
said Ronaldo stayed here last night
[Laughter]
maybe yeah uh is David Beckham
officially an American
David Beckham is an incredible human
being but is he American
let's claim him what is it I'm saying
let's just make him you know an official
American he saved MLS now twice L.A
which is amazing I said they're all
layers to this story I speak to the
great Ray Hudson yesterday if you don't
know who he is
um fans of this show you've probably
heard his Clips he's like the one the
crazy commentator poet philosopher who
when Messi scores used to commentate and
say things like he's out of his work and
mind he's got a food mixer down his
pants and it's set to beat stuff like
that so I interviewed him because Ray
Hudson played in the nasl he lives in
Fort Lauderdale I call him like Lionel
Messi's dad like that he adores this
human I wanted to get his reaction and
he said Lionel Messi is about to play on
the field that Pele played on in Fort
Lauderdale that Johan Cruyff played on
um the Beckham there's a lot of history
to this there's a lot of layers and one
of the Beautiful Stories I think is that
David Beckham did come over here at a
time when MLS was really struggling you
know there were 13 teams I think there's
now 29
um and it was his arrival that
transformed MLS legitimized it made many
other players think you know Beckham can
go there I will too commercially gave
the league heft and the fact that he
owns into Miami
um and was a part of the team
um who negotiated this deeply complex
and creative this was just a simple
question Roger yeah yeah that's biblical
David Beckham the Gap Lionel Messi
they're both American now right Dan
isn't that how it works it'd be it's a
great addition you're a great addition
David Ferriday great addition David
Beckham Rebecca Lowe great addition oh
she is a great addition she's a great
American and Dan um ultimately 23rd 2026
World Cup let's play Beckham in the
middle let's have Lionel Messi the
Lionel Messi just you know it's Lionel
no not in America not when he's American
that changes no here it's Lionel yeah
they changed his name at Ellis Island
they'll be like you're lying on now son
now get in there make some of yourself
it's the American way leonelia came here
with nothing you're now Lionel you we
see a future for you in this nation he
is Roger Bennett men in Blazers great to
talk to you great to be with you you
beautiful human being thanks for having
me thank you thank you very much Roger
Bennett always great to have Roger on we
appreciate his Insight his passion yeah
if you guys are going to applaud on that
side of the glass you got to turn your
microphone Roger better all right
[Applause]